is it better late than never definitely
there's no argument about that at all
uh the only way to get the infection
under control is to reduce the
transmission between people
and that involves uh social distancing
so
of course it's better late than never
well the government says
it could last a month uh but michael got
there was pretty clear
that they'll be driven by the data that
it could be extended and
given how long it took to bring cases
down to bring hospitalizations down
in the first wave how long realistically
do you think we're going to be
in a lockdown four well i that's a very
difficult question to answer but
um the lockdown this time is not as
severe as it was uh in the first time
round and so the only way to know is
going to be to see how
quickly the cases uh the new cases start
dropping
and of course as we know there's a a lag
between
a case developing and then
hospitalization and then the
terrible consequences of you know severe
illness or death
uh so it's a bit early to answer that
question but it's unlikely this time to
come down quite as fast as it did
during the first lockdown uh simply
because we have got schools open we have
got
more people working um and so the social
distancing is not quite as much as
during the first
knockdown period so you think that
there's a chance that this lockdown
could last
even longer than the first lockdown it's
obviously a possibility yes
and the only way to know is going to be
to really
count the cases as accurately as
possible identify them and
it should be apparent what rate the
numbers are dropping
um but of course they're not going up as
fast this time as they were during the
first knockdown either and the um
the the reproduction number the
so-called r nord
uh initially if this infection if people
just behave normally is about
three something like that so 10 people
infect 30.
at the moment the number is maybe 10
people affect between
12 and 17 or 18 something like that
so it has been growing slightly more
slowly but nevertheless
the doubling time is somewhere between
one week and two weeks
uh which is why it's essential that uh
these measures are brought in
you made the points uh that it's not
quite as strict as the last lockdown of
course we know we've got
nurseries schools universities are still
open
how difficult do you think it's going to
be to bring r down below one
with those educational settings still
open well it's possible
it's undoubtedly possible to do it but
it is just that much
harder and it does mean that we
individually and collectively have got
to
look after ourselves and in doing so
looking after others looking after each
others
and the other point that is absolutely
clear is that it is very very difficult
to separate the generations
so the idea that you could simply shield
the vulnerable and it would all be okay
it just isn't the case and so younger
people do look after older people
and you can see and uh patrick violence
and chris whitley have illustrated it
repeatedly that as time has gone on the
rise in infections which initially was
most in young people is now
getting into all generations of course
one of the times when generations mix is
over christmas everyone's hoping of
course that if we look down now we might
save christmas but realistically you
know level with us
we're not going to be able to have the
christmas that we usually have are we
where we all
get around inside our houses with our
grandparents with our parents get a bit
tipsy together
that's just not going to happen isn't it
well i'm in the virus i'm afraid it's
sublimely indifferent as to what day of
the week it is and indeed whether it's
christmas
uh or any other festival so
it does seem a bit unlikely that it's
going to be a completely normal
christmas that's for sure
um michael gove was talking a little bit
about the pressure
on the nhs that could have resulted if
we hadn't locked down
um of course sage will have seen all the
data
can you give us a bit of a sense of how
bad things could have been
without action um would the second wave
have been significantly worse than the
first wave
if it would if it hadn't been mitigated
by action undoubtedly
but we now have over 10 000 people in
hospital beds
if the doubling time let's say is about
two weeks that takes you to twenty
thousand
in two weeks and forty thousand uh two
weeks after that
now these are projections they're not
predictions
uh but nevertheless uh they're very
similar to the projections that were
made by
uh patrick valance and chris we see
which they talked about in a press
conference a few weeks ago
and as the numbers and the growth goes
up
then the the models tend to become much
more accurate
and of course and what everyone's
alarmed about is what that means for
deaths
over 40 000 people dying in the first
wave
how concerned was sage about the number
of people who may have died this winter
well i mean again if you just look at
the numbers now
it's around it's been over 300 deaths
per day for the last few days
um that number has gone up very sharply
it was a handful at the beginning of
september
and again if those numbers keep doubling
then you can
inexorably see what happens um and the
pressure
nhs is very high but at the end of the
day this is about
uh saving lives without trying to
diminish the
seriousness of the situation the r rate
has also dropped
over the last couple of days anyway um
some of the places in tier three
restrictions
such as liverpool have seen a reduction
in case numbers
is there a sense that we really needed
the national lockdown or
with the additional social distancing
measures in place could we have brought
the virus under control without it
well the the best way to nip it
the infection in the bud if i can use
that term is to
make take action as early as possible
and what was absolutely clear
is that why whilst the numbers are very
very high
in particularly in the north and in the
midlands nevertheless the growth rate
is similar across the whole country so
the southwest which has had a low number
of cases
the cases are growing there and indeed
the pressures on the hospital system
could come
quite quickly because they have a
somewhat smaller capacity going with a
smaller population
so the answer is cases are rising across
the country
there's no part of the country that's
immune to this
and uh it's good news of course that
it's starting to flatten in some parts
of the northeast and the northwest and i
mean that's a relief
because it does show that the tier three
measures as they've been setting out
have been
starting to work but you can see how
slowly it takes time
for that to happen and uh so there is a
very strong argument
for making sure that we control the
numbers as quickly as possible
i mean others argue that the toll of
lockdown
on people's mental health on other
people you know
maybe not accessing the nhs in the same
way on the economy on jobs on
livelihoods is
is really very devastating and and it
feels like we were almost in this
cycle of perpetual lockdowns what would
you say to people who say actually look
maybe we need to find a way of living
with the virus
well i mean you've illustrated the
really difficult dilemma
for the politicians who have to decide
and let me be absolutely clear
the job of scientists is to advise we're
not elected it is actually the job of
the people that we elected
of government are held to account by
parliament to make these very difficult
decisions
and everyone recognizes that there are
all sorts of
very severe consequences of the
infection that go far beyond the actual
infection itself so the risk that people
don't get
hospital treatment and clinical
treatment for other conditions
the risk to the loss of education future
generations
mental health costs of being lonely and
isolated
the costs in terms of loss of jobs
damage to the economy
that's the terrible terrible dilemma for
our policy makers who are our
politicians and as michael gove
said you could see people with
politicians struggling across
europe and if ever there was an
illustration that humans are puny in the
face of nature it's this
and it doesn't matter whether it's an
earthquake a tsunami or infectious
disease
nature is very very hard to beat but i
mean there is some good news in all this
and that is that the treatments are
better than they were
first time around and so hopefully the
mortality in hospitals will be
significantly lower
the testing regime though far from
perfect there are at least now tests
available which there weren't at the
beginning
and there is the hope that vaccines will
come along
and that's really the reason that it
would be a mistake just to say okay
uh the other consequences oh hi we'll
just let this infection
rip because there are so many people
that have not been infected
and it's not as though the only adverse
outcome to health
is death in the elderly it is actually
the so-called long-covered there are
many young people that actually are very
severely debilitated
for quite long periods by this infection
it's not a nice infection
and just finally you know you mentioned
that some of the positives like the fact
that we are getting better treating
at covid when do you think the cavalry
is going to finally arrive you know in
the form of an
effective treatment or a vaccine how
long we got to wait
well i mean even with a sort of very
sensitive air it's quite difficult
to hear the cavity actually coming over
the hill but i mean we know
scientifically that there
are a significant number of vaccines uh
in development we know that they can
elicit a strong
immune response um and uh
similarly we know that there are
anti-inflammatory drugs which weren't
there before
um antibodies which might block the the
binding of the the uptake of the virus
are being trialled
so there are a lot of things uh being
tried
and uh it i i per se i'm reasonably
optimistic that a combination of these
will
bring this under control because if we
were back in 1918 with flu there would
have been nothing that we could do
and so i think we'd be having a
different discussion but we are having
this discussion in the context that
people are being looked after better
because we know more about it
and there is the genuine prospect of
better treatments
preventive agents and vaccines